تعلم CNN حصريًا عن حملة جديدة لوكالة المخابرات المركزية
وتهدف هذه الحملة إلى
تجنيد الروس للتجسس لصالح
الولايات المتحدة، حيث حصل أليكس ماركوارت على مقطع
فيديو رائع من وكالة المخابرات المركزية
مع رسالتهم التي تهدف إلى جذب
الروس وتحويلهم ضد بوتين،
إنها قصة ستستمتع بها  شاهد أولاً
الأسئلة [الموسيقى] التي يتم طرحها باللغة الروسية في مقطع
فيديو درامي جديد أصدرته وكالة المخابرات المركزية للتو
لمحاولة تجنيد المزيد من
الجواسيس الروس من خلال مناشدة
الإحباطات الوطنية الروسية والقمع الذي
يواجهونه في ظل نظام بوتين،
قال مسؤولون في وكالة المخابرات المركزية لشبكة CNN في مقابلة
مقابلة حصرية: لقد خلقت الحرب في أوكرانيا
فرصة غير مسبوقة
يريدون الاستفادة منها لتجنيد
أصول روسية جديدة، وسيستمر السخط من الحرب في نخر
القيادة الروسية في ظل
الحمية الثابتة من دعاية الدولة والقمع الذي تمارسه
في العام الماضي.  خلال الحرب،
كانت وكالة المخابرات المركزية تشجع الروس الذين
لديهم معلومات قيمة على الاتصال
بهم بهدوء وبشكل آمن ومجهول
من خلال بوابة على شبكة الإنترنت المظلمة، ونحن
نبحث في جميع أنحاء العالم عن الروس
الذين يشعرون بالاشمئزاز من ذلك كما
نحن لأننا منفتحون على الأعمال التجارية.
تم نشر التعليمات على
حسابات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التابعة لوكالة المخابرات المركزية وهذا
الفيديو الجديد بعد تقديم عرض عاطفي للمشاهدين
الروس يوضح كيفية القيام بذلك
باستخدام متصفح الويب المظلم المسمى Tor،
أنت لست عاجزًا، يقول اتصل بنا
بطريقة آمنة تجنيد وكالة المخابرات المركزية
تم نشر الفيديو لأول مرة مساء الاثنين على تطبيق
Telegram، وهو تطبيق الوسائط الاجتماعية الذي
يحظى بشعبية كبيرة بين الروس الذين لا يستطيعون
الوصول بسهولة إلى الأخبار غير المفلترة أو
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الأخرى التي أسميها تعليق الألواح
الخشبية ونشر الكلمة على
نطاق واسع بأن الولايات المتحدة وأخصائيي
مكافحة الظواهر هي  مفتوح للعمل
ولدينا جيوب عميقة، إذا كنت تريد
الرد على هذا الرجل الذي
تكرهه فلاديمير بوتين، فلديك
فرصة الآن للقيام بذلك بأمان، وقال مسؤولو وكالة المخابرات المركزية لشبكة
CNN إنهم يأملون أن
يتردد صدى الفيديو خارج نطاق
مسؤولي المخابرات والأمن مع الأشخاص الذين قد
لا يدركون أن لديهم
معلومات حساسة لمشاركتها، على سبيل المثال
في مجال تمويل التكنولوجيا السيبرانية والمجالات الأخرى
التي قد يعتقدون أن الاتصال بوكالة المخابرات المركزية أمر
صعب للغاية أو خطير للغاية. أخبرت وكالة المخابرات المركزية شبكة
CNN أنهم يريدون إزالة الغموض عن أننا
بحاجة إلى أشخاص من جميع أنحاء
الاقتصاد الروسي للتعاون  معنا، نحن بحاجة إلى
معرفة ما يحدث في هذا البلد المعادي،
لا يوجد ذكر مباشر لبوتين أو
أوكرانيا، ولا يصر مسؤولو وكالة المخابرات المركزية على ما إذا كان
المقصود منه تأجيج الاضطرابات في روسيا، بل
يقولون لشبكة CNN أن هذه موضوعات خالدة
يأملون أن تدفع الروس إلى
الحرب.  أسلحة وكالة المخابرات المركزية
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بما رأته وكالة المخابرات المركزية بالفعل
في جهودهم لتجنيد
جواسيس روس جدد خلال هذه الحرب، يقولون
إنهم كانوا ناجحين، أخبرني أحد مسؤولي وكالة المخابرات المركزية
في كلماته أن هناك
اتصالات قادمة الآن، لقد فاز آرون  لا
نعطي أي أرقام أو نقول أين
يعمل هؤلاء الروس، لكن وكالة المخابرات المركزية تقول إنهم
لم يكونوا لينشروا هذا الفيديو الجديد
إذا لم يحققوا بعض النجاح بالفعل،
ويجب أن نلاحظ أيضًا أن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
حاول تجنيد جواسيس روس
هنا في واشنطن.  مع الإعلانات التي تستهدف على وجه التحديد
الأشخاص القادمين والمغادرين من
السفارة الروسية، وهو جهد
وصفته السفارة بأنه سخيف، آرون أليكس،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، إنه مهم في
هذا السياق على الرغم من أنه مجرد ملاحظة
للجميع، فهناك الكثير من
الروس الذين يخرجون من السفارة
الولايات المتحدة أن هذا لا يزال هو
الواقع تمامًا الآن، ألينا
بولياكوفا هي
خبيرة في الشؤون الخارجية الروسية والرئيس والمدير التنفيذي
لمركز تحليل السياسات الأوروبية،
لذلك ألينا وأنت تسمع
مقاطع فيديو التوظيف هذه والتي فقط تكون
واضحة  على Telegram، يقوم Alex
بالإبلاغ عن المكان الذي
يقضي فيه الروس الكثير من الوقت وهو وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، وهي
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي السائدة في
روسيا، فماذا تسمع عندما تسمع
مقاطع الفيديو هذه والنداء الذي
يبذلونه للاحتفاظ به  كرامتك لرعاية
عائلتك
أعني سماع اللغة الروسية
التي يتم التحدث بها في مقاطع الفيديو هذه
الآن، أعتقد أنها رائعة للغاية
وبصراحة، هناك الكثير من الروس الذين
لن نسمع منهم أبدًا ممن يشعرون
بخيبة أمل من المستقبل  إنهم يرون
أمامهم مستقبلًا كئيبًا للغاية في
عهد الرئيس بوتين ولن
نسمعهم أبدًا يتحدثون عن هذا علنًا
لأن الناس في روسيا
خائفون جدًا حقًا من نوع العقوبة
التي قد تأتي مع قول أي شيء
علنًا، كما تعلمون.  تذكر أن هذا
البلد سوف يرميك في السجن بسبب
حملك ورقة بيضاء
لا تحتوي على كلمات، لذلك أعتقد أن هذه
خدعة رائعة من قبل وكالة المخابرات المركزية
لمعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاننا الحصول على بعض المخبرين أه
الأشخاص العاديين للتعاون  مع
الولايات المتحدة والآن ألينا سمعت
ما يقوله أليكس وهو يقول إن
وكالة المخابرات المركزية تعرف أنه بمعنى أن لديهم
عائدًا على الاستثمار أنهم
يفعلون ذلك لأنهم
ولديهم اتصالات قادمة بالفعل، هل
تعتقد أن هذا  أشير إلى المخاطر التي يواجهها
الروس الذين تتحدث إليهم والمتواجدين
داخل روسيا والذين قد يرون أن
متصفح الويب المظلم هذا الذي سيتجول في هذا الأمر
هو شيء
سيأخذه الأشخاص بعدد كافٍ من الأشخاص أعتقد أنهم
سيخاطرون بالنظر
إليه  من الصعب جدًا الوصول إلى
النغمة الصحيحة، كما تعلم، نوع الرسالة التي
سمعناها للتو في هذا المقطع لن
يروق للجميع أه بعض
الناس سوف يضحكون عليها ولكن
من المفترض أه أنهم حصلوا على أشياء من
التعاون مع
أجهزة المخابرات هنا  قد يحصلون على بعض
المدفوعات وقد يحصلون على الأمن، كما
تعلم، هذه هي الأشياء التي
يتوق إليها الكثير من الروس حقًا في الوقت الحالي، لذلك هناك
جاذبية معينة هناك حيث
ستصل إلى عدد كبير من الأشخاص الذين
لا نعرفهم أه ولكن أعتقد أن  ربما تعتمد وكالة المخابرات المركزية
على حقيقة أنه حسنًا،
حتى لو وصل الأمر إلى بضع عشرات من الأشخاص الذين يتخذون
الخطوات اللازمة والذين يشعرون
بالارتياح للقيام بذلك، فهذا يعد بالفعل
فوزًا ولينا. سؤال آخر
كان أليكس يتحدث عنه أن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي يحاول
تجنيد أشخاص قادمين من
السفارة الروسية وهذا يجعلك
تدرك أن هناك الكثير من الأشخاص أه
الذين يجدون طرقًا للمجيء والذهاب من
روسيا داخل وخارج الولايات المتحدة
الموجودين هنا بشكل قانوني تمامًا أه
قادرين على القيام بذلك هناك روس
أيضًا الذين  تأتي وتذهب من أماكن أخرى
بأعداد كبيرة ربما تعرف أماكن
في الولايات المتحدة على سبيل المثال. هل تعتقد
أنه كان هناك نجاح في التجنيد
بين تلك المجموعة
مرة أخرى، من الصعب معرفة أننا لا
نعرف ما الذي تفعله وكالات الاستخبارات؟
لن نشارك هذا
النوع من المعلومات معنا ولكن
بالطبع هناك العديد من الروس الذين
ما زالوا يأتون إلى الولايات المتحدة
كسائحين. ليس من السهل الحصول على
تأشيرة سياحية بالطبع بالنسبة لمعظم الروس ولكن
أولئك الذين لديهم المال والقدرات اللازمة
ثروة للسفر للذهاب إلى
بلد آخر إلى جانب روسيا للحصول على التأشيرة، من
المستحيل في الأساس الحصول على تأشيرة دخول إلى
الولايات المتحدة في روسيا اليوم، لكن
انظر إذا كان لديك تأشيرة للذهاب إلى
ألمانيا أو إستونيا، فربما لا يكون الأمر
بهذه الصعوبة بالنسبة لك  إذا كنت على استعداد
للانتظار، فأعتقد بالتأكيد أن
هناك فرصًا هائلة هنا، فنحن نعلم
أن العديد من الروس، وخاصة أولئك
الذين هم أكثر ثراءً والذين ينتمون إلى
الطبقة المتوسطة،
تعرفون من يريدون نوعًا مختلفًا من
الحياة لأنفسهم  كما تعلم، سوف
يأتون إلى الغرب ويريدون
العيش مثل الغربيين، ولا يريدون
العيش في مجتمع قمعي
بمستقبل قاتم، حسنًا، إيلينا، شكرًا جزيلاً لك،
أنا أقدر ذلك،
شكرًا لك